[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever
we want that's what i wanted to talk
about
verb no no i just came out that was the
talk so strong opinions
do you know how to fake burp i can never
fake it
just like that yeah like that just
forcing one out how do you do that
you did that can you do that i used to
be are you telling
that's where i picked it up i was
jealous of the kids that could do that
and the kids that could flip their
[ __ ] no i hated that
you just have to switch i did one side
my air
yeah and then your eyes will flip in and
please nobody do it in the room
i feel like bart's like dying to do it
right now right what i don't know i
thought
it's the one that would do that [ __ ] i i
don't i never did the eye flip
i did do the hand and the armpit that
yeah yeah oh i could do that one yeah
i don't know if i still can because
after i grew armpit hair it stopped
yeah that is good all right go shave it
right now
it's not as it's not as strong as it you
guys ever do the opposite where you
actually farted and you're just like
[Laughter]
auditory replication of fart noises is
something i think we've all done in
certain places
like you'll fart and then you're like oh
yeah i know
i love farting and blaming people yeah
yeah i was i would like fart and i'll be
like oh you farted they're like no
no no i didn't you did and then
everyone's like oh you farted
and i'm if you were ever my opponent in
politics i would be like this guy farts
and blames people and then i play the
clip all the time
everywhere he went that's a [ __ ]
third grader
you particularly no i played you talked
about it now as a man
do you guys fart in planes cause you're
like all the time if you're not gonna go
in there for four hours i mean
[ __ ] you can't move and if you hold on
to it you know it's not it's gonna hurt
it's not gonna feel good
yeah you're in the weirdest position to
hold a fart i hold them though
you hold them for the whole flight you
want indigestion bathroom
and it hurts yes you're right but then
the minute you stand up the feeling goes
away and you sit back down and come back
yeah it's weird like that's what you're
doing on the plane you're like oh
no i don't know oh [ __ ] i got gas from
the probably the stupid cold sandwich
that i bought for fifteen dollars
and then i get up and i'm like oh wait
went away and i go sit back down and it
comes back again i'm like i might as
well just fart here
well what sucks is like uh because you
know how the air circulates in the plane
so i didn't know that he used to do that
and i would get
so pissed at like the people walking by
because it always smells like it's
coming from like
away from us this way like forward it
had to be dogging people and [ __ ] i
always turned the fans off
meanwhile you turned to bart and he's
like [ __ ] sweating all over the place
and i'm like there's so many [ __ ]
nasty people that are farting and he's
like i know right it's [ __ ] crazy
i take the table down to his smell no
because the air
there's so much air you know like
everyone has it because he has a
distinctive smell he does
but it travels so much because of the
air that circulates that like it
it you get a whiff of it mixed with
other people yeah
yeah and then just the plain smell and
then like eventually he told me that it
was him doing i'm like you [ __ ]
like i'm there
dying the whole time i've told you that
i did and you would have felt better
about it
[Laughter]
but she's like man people these days
stinks like everyone farts around my
head
on planes i'm sick of planes
dude i was on a plane to vegas and you
know how sometimes they give you those
it's a smaller plane so they have those
two seats
it's just two seats like two and two no
yeah so um
i got sentence to this cat and
unfortunately i had a bart fart
where it was just so nuts you had one it
smelled like dead eggs oh [ __ ]
dead eggs it was nuts bro that is bart's
fart i know just remember yeah that's
the bart's fart to describe it for all
of you
at home uh so then i i just tried it i
was like oh am i really gonna try this i
was like i'll try it and i was just like
like it wasn't mine and the cat next to
me was like visibly like
[ __ ] like and i was just like right
you know right it was crazy like there's
nobody around like there's nobody
like up there so i'm like i'm like
trying to make him think the vertex of
the wind in there like was
piping around did he have
suspecting eyes if it was him i would
have suspected him too but why didn't he
just go what would i have to well well
no he was the one on the inside of the
aisle i was on the outside of the arnold
so he was
mr [ __ ] basically but i don't know
what to do in that situation should i
just shoot
that that's when you beat joe as soon as
you do it
[Laughter]
to the whole plane i would like to make
an announcement
yeah i had a moment like that with a guy
where we both smelled something at the
same time and we looked at each other
and we were
just like nah it's not me and then he
was like nudging my shoulder and he
pointed
and this lady had her shoes off and it
stuck so [ __ ] bad and it didn't smell
like fart it did smell like feet
so that's why i was like that's pretty
bad that she can be three rolls away we
can see her feet
and it's stunk that bad that's why yeah
is his shoes off
nah all of our shoes were on he was just
trying to blame it on someone else he
busted a joke
and he looked down like wait your shoes
are off too
yeah stinky [ __ ] that's a bile weapon
dude but yeah we have
ricky sharks back today
i forgot about that yeah i was like
introduced to the
he's an old bud though terrible host you
were just sitting there like trying to
like come in
welcome back thank you what's your name
these days how was your
2020 thing because you haven't been on
jk news in 2020 he's representing 2020
my 2020 has been [ __ ] awesome really
yeah i don't know i don't know how but
it's been great like
business is booming lakers won makers
one
dodgers one doctors i don't care about
baseball but
go dodgers i'm happy for y'all two 32
years or some [ __ ] like that mm-hmm
that's a three-peat
for l.a yeah
but that would be crazy how are the rams
okay never mind i don't do football
they have a [ __ ] offense that's all true
i think a lot of people from l.a are
just going to follow the raiders and go
to las vegas
dude i know i'm going to vegas vegas
raiders
yep raiders hey man
it's cool because a lot of people that
i've been talking to
say the same thing that you do 2020 has
been like really [ __ ] amazing
or it started off weird like they're
like
like i don't know where this is gonna go
but it actually went yeah everyone's
unsure in the beginning
yeah but i also am around a lot of
positive people so maybe
they just know how to make a shitty
situation good right so
you'd be the best guy to have a covered
funeral because you're sitting there and
you're like
it's been pretty great for me sorry guys
he's not having a good year just to be
clear he's not having a good year okay
it sucks
[ __ ] it's eye opener
clearly i know it sucked for other
people that [ __ ] that sucks but for me
perfectly
it was great that's fantastic but do you
feel
weird saying that um no when we're
talking about me personally yeah 2020
itself has been
[ __ ] weird it's been terrible but for
me personally
that's what i'm saying and then so but a
lot of uh people
feel like like you shouldn't though yeah
they'll be like how can you be saying
that when there's suffrage in the world
people been suffering [ __ ] 24 7.
all day long even pre-corona i get you
on that though
i do feel a little weird talking about
like just
how much fun i'm having you know you
know especially when you're meeting
someone new
when you're meeting someone new you
don't really know what their personality
or or like their stances are on things
and then and you know you feel obligated
to kind of share yourself to kind of
break the ice
i have a hard time breaking the ice now
because i have no idea what is
appropriate anymore i'm like well these
things are going well for me and then
you know you say it out loud and you're
like
well if you know their 2020 sucks and i
feel kind of like weird
rubbing in their face or something well
i feel like you only say that if
somebody asked you how i was going
why the [ __ ] are they
but you're very honest because you're
like my 20's kicking ass casey's like
oh i don't know um
[Music]
[Laughter]
what do you mean what about my 2020 what
about your 2020 no i don't know
honestly honestly i don't really get
into 2020.
i don't talk about it yeah it's kind of
like not a dinner table kind of talk you
know like i don't want to talk about
this kind of [ __ ]
religion politics in 2020 i know right
what about all your friends and family
do they are they having a good time um
yes all of them i don't know
i don't know anybody who's like
it's really hitting hard like that which
is
a blessing yeah but i do know that there
are people out there that's [ __ ] him
up
my dad he he actually called me and then
i was like we were just talking about
how are you doing
he goes i'm doing really good he's an
introvert he's like i'm doing really
good and he's like but everyone
else going outside catching it
he goes all these stupid [ __ ]
going out
why do you think i've been staying
inside for the last 60 years
i knew corona and speaking of stupid
[ __ ] going out
today's episode's sponsored by postmates
that's right baby
what a great way to segue
because um i just got back from colorado
and
um you know i live with aunt now and
he's got the kids
and then he's like yo man you want some
dinner and i'm like
yeah he goes but you can't come in and
i'm like i understand and he goes but
i'm gonna order you some [ __ ]
so what do you end up doing he posted
post mated me
some delivery and then he came over to
my room with this which is the garage
right
and he dropped it off and we had dinner
that way oh sweet guy
with the shirt still up with the shirts
still yeah yeah
no he went back to his own i i just ate
alone but like it was the thought you
know what i mean like it was [ __ ]
cool
you guys ever facetime and have dinner
together that would be hilarious
no i end up just eating um at in their
living room i mean their their kitchen
yeah that's tight if you're like me you
start thinking about what to eat for
dinner
while you're eating lunch i love food
but sometimes getting into my kitchen
and cooking something delicious to eat
just doesn't make it on my to-do list
which is why i've been loving
postmates with postmates you can get
food delivered just like how joe
explained
without leaving the house or even
opening your front door
with the current state of the world in
mind post mates created no contact
deliveries they usually just leave it
right there
so now when i order from local
restaurants everything gets left on my
doorstep and the app lets me know when
it's delivered
postmates also offers a pickup option
which i've been using to order takeout
from my favorite local restaurants
it's so important that we support and
uplift our communities right now
amen and what better way than ordering
food
and postmates isn't all just burgers and
sushi like i said they ordered pho
i can order anything from toilet paper
to phone chargers from stores like
walgreens and 7-eleven
and a postmate will drop it off right
outside my front door
or aunt's front door just download
postmates on ios or android and find
your favorites and get anything you want
delivered within the
hour for a limited time postmates is
giving our listeners
five dollars off your first five orders
so each order is five bucks off for your
first seven days to save
five dollars on your first five
deliveries download the app
and use the code off the record that's
code off the record for five dollars off
your first five orders when you download
the post mates app
or sign up online anything you need
anytime you need it post made it whoa
thank you postmates thanks postmates
what a great segue that was one of the
best
yesterday i i didn't know how to do it
that was a good segue too yesterday's
like i don't know how to segue this so
today's video
is [ __ ] awesome that'll be in the
james rodolfo segway highlander
that'll be tight actually i've been
seeing chase rodolfo make
videos in a while yeah he might be
but it's just not showing up on our feed
because the [ __ ] algorithm is [ __ ]
enough oh
true true normal dolphin is this guy who
uh
makes a lot of compilation videos for us
and they'll like
do best doves or like he does really
good job but you polite laughs so well
thank you for that
bro i've worked with uh tim
i know how to feel like i'm on the no
chaser podcast bro
i gotta i gotta do it for six hours a
day bro oh [ __ ]
good stuff uh geo yesterday you were
wearing a ball gown today
you're wearing fatigues
you wearing a ball gown no it was like a
silky dress
because i had an event after i think i
got you figured out though okay go
i've been playing this game called
fortnite with uh yours your son
yeah he has shown me this game and when
you're in a character creator
you can basically just have jio's
wardrobe and you make a chick and then
you dress them like geo i think that
your
style is fortnite chicks oh
fortnite style because they were like a
ball gown and then yesterday you had
like this cool coat on top of it yeah
and like kids like to think they love to
do that [ __ ] and then today you're doing
fatigues and like chill and you've got
the big glasses and [ __ ] and they like
to do that [ __ ]
you tell me cool yeah thank you i think
you're up to date bro with all the
all the traffic thanks i think it was an
accident
but the fact that you can go ball gown
to fatigues in one day
and none of us even blinks by the way
we're used to it
yeah yeah it's time she could wear like
ball gown and a bathrobe
with earmuffs and none of us are going
to be like
weirdo but if i do it i get judged
no if you come in full bondage with the
ball gag we're like hey joe good morning
i feel the eyes on me
that's true i want to try doing a jk
news in a ball gag one day though
that'll be pretty funny because remember
we could speak with that big guy
he's drawing all of ours it wouldn't be
so different they drool good for you
i didn't know that i'll try it out i
haven't tried it yet
no it's not my thing i like to be more
dominant but then not that kind of
submissive
more like bend me over and lick my ass
submissive
that's a different kind of submissive
but don't get it yeah i thought i was
being dominant by doing that but
actually it's amazing
where was i going with this oh yeah i
was inspired by nelson
because he had a face mask and he had to
be like kenny and we had to write
subtitles well not we but the shout outs
to the editors for doing that
painstaking job
of writing subtitles for him because he
was russell
muffled the whole time he sounded like
kenny so i'm like that'll be so dope
if i'm doing jk news and no one can
understand me and then they
have to write subtitles that's literally
right now dude
that happens literally right now well i
say ball gag day i'm in
trouble all right i think we have a ball
gag here on are you serious
i think we've had i wouldn't want to put
that in our mouth from our skin days i
think we have a lot of
[ __ ] dude me and nicky we just got
airbnb down in
laguna beach for a weekend that show was
nuts well no
so we got into the airbnb and there's a
corner of the room
that has a big steel x wow
and it had bondage like everything
bondage cuffs
bondage collars like a [ __ ] ball gag
like it was kind of like a funky ass
place already but it had like this whole
bondage set up was that for you guys to
use
well i don't know i think it's there for
photos honestly what's the x for like
don't touch it's like no it's like
youtube wires probably yeah it's
probably you can chain somebody up to it
i don't know yes
yeah yeah yeah you definitely it's it's
exactly for that right so that kind of
stuff
no i you just threw the well you did
have the swing at your house
we do have a swing yeah but it's a
bohemian like
[Laughter]
it looks kind of babies yeah very trendy
like bondage is getting a revamp it's
bohemian you like wait your style of
bondage like
more you know canvas and like woven
fabrics and it's not so
like vinyl i thought you're like you
guys have a sex man outside and it's
just one of those outdoor swing chairs
[ __ ] playground
[Laughter]
it's the community playground and [ __ ]
look at these [ __ ] perverts
bondage everywhere you live here i know
you know what's funny is they would use
exercise equipment and just add a dick
to everything
like they have that bouncy
not played not kid stuff no yeah so you
would have a bouncy ball with a dick
you know they just have regular the
medicine ball thing with the dick
yeah bart sold those i did that yup did
you know that's something
was it popular um so i helped so i had a
buddy
he sold sex toys on ebay and because his
dad had access to like plastics
manufacturing in china
so for him he's just a businessman he
just saw the margins like a dildo he can
get for like five bucks and sell it for
50.
that's where he that's great he's like
cha-ching but his english wasn't good so
i would be the one helping him write all
the pictures
exactly that'd help him right all the
copy like oh this is like very erotic or
it makes like your [ __ ] dripping wet or
whatever now
oh god i'm writing all the copy for all
the for all his toys so i don't know how
the sales were
like i wasn't keeping track of that but
it seemed like they did well so you
started your marketing career
you're marketing money sex toys and
talking about dripping [ __ ] and stuff
yes can you actually describe
like okay so let's picture this is just
a medicine ball with a dick on top of it
can you
please fill in that description for us
he's really good
he's gonna blow you away i don't i don't
know you're saying the bar to high
uh you're not gonna want to buy anything
maybe it has to start off with uh
you see perfect solution to the dark
lonely lonely lonely night i'm moist
okay a little bit okay it's working for
rick yeah
if you miss the thrust of the thrust
of being dominated from all directions
oh 36 inch baby blue ball
with a 12-inch penis well satisfied i
don't know
i loved it you gave up it was going a
good place you set the scene you told me
why
yeah you told me how yeah yeah start he
started with a problem yeah and i gave a
couple features this 36 inch ball
12 inch penis and you knew what you're
going to be doing i wanted to yeah yeah
all directions all directions yeah yeah
because you can hold the ball and go up
against the wall too
oh bounce it off the wall and do all
kinds of stuff did you make
instructional videos then
i didn't anyone with a hole can
appreciate it
yes that's true everyone has a hole yup
this ball does not discriminate
some people don't have holes guys who i
don't know but
you have to say that [ __ ] you have to
cover all bases
this year yeah you know everyone has a
whole bra
you might have a fan that's like
actually i was born without an [ __ ]
let's see
and i had to get surgery and attach a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bag on the back of my neck see and
then we're like yep
you're still talking with your mouth
yeah and that's a hole that's a whole
hole to me
yup everyone's got a hole
you